I think I use social media as an outlet
for me to help me
I'm showing other people that they're
not alone
I don't know who needs to hear this
today but
it's okay to not be okay
I had never experienced anything like
that I mean people are like it's because
she's a girl it's extra hormones and
this and that but I was not myself
[Music]
and you're a girl dad now oh yeah but
she's like a boy don't say that you how
do you want that right now no no he has
no idea
listen to the earrings right oh yeah
I got a lot of mom shame for piercing
her ears when I did but you know what
everybody's like oh my gosh look at all
your boys she's a girl and also she's
never gonna remember it do you know what
I mean I got a lot of hate from Mom like
a lot of backlash how did she react she
didn't even cry really she didn't even
cry Bing bam boom did it at the doctor's
office like I didn't go to some Josh Moe
you know and you know she's got earrings
she looks great you're used to
navigating that though by now right what
all of the opinions
yeah I still have my moments I will tell
you it's very very hard to imagine you
know you have a million beautiful
comments and then there's one that just
sticks out and listen you want to talk
about me fine but my kids are off limits
I'm gonna go put her down and cover yeah
hi
adorable okay
honey you want some more all right you
hate the attention
we made our model
if she gets in my height that's it yeah
we're in trouble
how do you deal with the mom shame and
how is Alex
there to support you I'm mostly good
with it but there are times where
something will stick out and like he's
at work I don't want to bother him but
it just upsets me so much I cry I also
get on social media with it because I
think it's important for other moms to
know hey I deal with it too well at the
beginning I always told her not to read
not to listen not to you know but it's
easier said than done first of all and
second of all she is an influencer
online so
you know for her it's kind of impossible
to to not and to not listen and to not
response
therefore I just tell her to take it all
into proportion and that's it but she
she's the one who responds I don't even
read them it doesn't bother me I don't
care sometimes she defends me she
defends me I see somebody posts
something mean about me she'll jump oh
so yeah yeah that's hard it's an outlet
yeah
like question your decisions or whether
you trust yourself or not all the time
and I think that's the worst part
like I'm a mom of three I should know
what to do right but there's no right or
wrong and that's what makes everybody
unique but there are times where there
are some wrongs though
no but you know what I mean like I there
are times where I question it and I'm
like wait should I have done that or oh
my gosh I didn't know that and am I a
bad mom and but that's right too that's
okay to to find out things that you
didn't know I find out things that I
didn't know all the time it's okay to
make mistakes yeah it's not always shame
you don't need to take it as shaming all
the time if somebody gives you an advice
and it's the decision
behind it yeah
um yeah so but sometimes I read
something that I didn't realize and I'm
like okay great now I know yeah well
something that we love about you on
social media your authenticity you
opened up about your postpartum Journey
after having Ari why was it important
for you to share what you shared and be
so vulnerable you were as you call it
ugly crying oh I have such an ugly cry
but you know what but it's okay
everybody has an ugly cry I think I use
social media as an outlet for me to help
me
I'm showing other people that they're
not alone and in turn that's helping me
realize I'm not alone like with the
postpartum it's it's hard but with Ari I
had never experienced anything like that
I just want you to know that if you're
not okay
it's really okay
and you're not alone
trust me you're not alone I mean people
are like it's because she's a girl it's
extra hormones and this and that but I
was not what was that were you just sad
what was it I was angry I was sad it was
so hard because she was in the NICU I
and like I had to get up every day
because of my boys and there were times
where I was just like Alex like just
leave me alone I went into the shower
like yeah I'll just leave me alone like
um and I went into the shower and I
would cry in the shower and
and now I mean I'm I definitely think
I'm out of that the dark dark phase but
there I still have my moments yeah trust
me does it bring you peace to know that
it is postpartum because you know some
people deal with that Darkness but
they're like I'm just sad and I don't
know why you know does that give you
some keys a little bit but then like the
other day I saw all of our kids and I
started crying and I was my heart was
so full and hurting at the same time wow
it's just weird I don't know maybe it's
baby blues maybe it's all the hormones I
think this time it was harder for her
because
she knew that is the last one at this
point that's her that's that's the
thought so she was upset I could hear
people saying No Maybe not maybe not but
in her mind at this point in life it's
the last one so that's why it made her
more upset yeah and um
I'm glad she's going on social media so
so it's not all on me
but now he's like go on social media
yeah and um and it's helpful to her I
think we both learned that opening up
helps not just you know the people who
are listening but also the person we
learned that when you know when you open
up about Tourette syndrome and it helped
her so it's like you know it's good for
for everybody that's true the whole
you're not alone yeah it sounds like you
know just a cliche that people say but
it's so true when you know someone else
is going through a similar thing it just
it helps I do it selfishly because it
helps me I get messages all the time and
I'm like oh my God thank God it's not
just me right I'm normally not yeah
right exactly yeah very helpful I love
that I love that okay so we're complete
as a party of five right now five as of
now okay all right well now Lauren we
talked about this mommy makeover
yeah I want to get tightened and tucked
and enhanced but I want to come out like
a mummy
but but I'm not doing it now I'm
starting a lifestyle change I've started
doing this journey and I've been doing
it for a few weeks and I've lost a lot
of weight on it naturally
thank you I'm watching what I eat I'm
doing a food program it's it's
progression not not Perfection is what I
say and that's what it is like I've been
pregnant since 2019 and I need to let my
body adjust to it so I'm doing it the
right way yeah and I'm very very happy
with the results so far good because
some people you know they get that
surgery girl and if they don't have the
lifestyle
it's so waste in some cases yeah I'm
gonna say that I'm very proud of her for
doing it this way I really trust her she
really is doing a lifestyle change where
before and also other people sometimes
just want to lose everything fast and
that's it that's right then then it
doesn't stick it doesn't right but she's
making this change and I'm very proud of
her and support her and
you look great honey thank you
I'm not sure shut the up
that's not disrespectful you know that's
not disrespectful I didn't have a room
full of people I'd probably slap you in
the face because you're disrespectful
to your mother are you watching the show
back we are not watching the show yeah
because we lived it okay well what's
been the hardest part about knowing that
that bike has been exposed to the world
I mean listen families fight every
family has problems ours is just out
there now yeah and
I will I will say it has changed the
family Dynamic it's not like we are real
people we have real feelings and
emotions and we have to go through
everything just like everybody else
um but it's out there now yeah a little
tense yeah how would you describe your
relationship with your parents today
boundaries
and I think that they're starting to
see it
but it's better than oh yeah it's
definitely better but I think they're
seeing that I've put out boundaries now
I think that the whole stuff was was
coming if it wasn't this for for the
movie was coming some other way because
it's true like
Lauren's parents are very involved and
she and she doesn't have no boundaries
backbone she doesn't have no boundaries
they they control her a lot and
sometimes it's good sometimes it's not
but it's time to start you know being
your own it's part of my lifestyle
change also for real like I do I'm just
this situation that happened in Israel
was the best and worst thing that
happened because it made me open my eyes
and I finally heard Alex and like myself
and
like now I just I know the kind of mom
that I want to be don't want to be and
how I want to navigate situations
differently yeah yeah so it turned out
super lining in it
you could see it there but it definitely
changed a little bit the dynamic yeah
well at this moment are you still
considering moving to Israel yeah yeah
definitely happening it's going to
happen at some point maybe it's not
gonna happen tomorrow and so fast like
we were trying to make it happen but
it's I think it's gonna happen yeah
[Music]
foreign